if you are faced with the question what
is the zeifer compass, what do I need
it for, how can I calculate it now and, above
all, how do I interpret the results,
then you are in the right place and we
will start right away with the first question,
what do I actually need the compass for,
let's say you have it  a hypothesis is
formulated in which a variable that cannot be
measured directly a so-called
latent variable occurs so that latent
variables can be made
measurable a scale is used what is
a scale now a scale is a group
of questions, for example question 1 to
question 4, which serve this purpose together
to measure a latent variable
the individual questions in a scale
are called items the goal is now
that the answers to the various
items agree well, i.e. combine highly
each of the individual questions should combine with each
other as highly as possible if
the answers to the questions university speaks their own language
one of a high internal
consistency and now are  we also arrived at the
compass alpha because it is precisely
this internal consistency that the
compass alpha measures because krombacher is
a measure of the internal consistency of a
scale
the compass alpha is a measure of the
extent to which the groups of questions
are related to one another and thus gives
an estimate of how  good or
bad the measuring accuracy the
so-called g lability a group of
items is very important but the compass zeal does not check whether the
individual items are really only influenced by one
or more latent variables
a high value of compass alpha is
no proof that the  items are only influenced by
one latent
variable so that the rehabilitation
can be estimated using the comma alfers, the condition must be met
that all questions or
items measure the same latent variable
that means if all items measure the same
latent variable then the
compass says alpha  how good this i  tems
measure the latent variable so now
let’s give you an example first of all let’s say you made the hypothesis
extroverted people earn more
salary than introverted people it’s
painful now the salary that’s
easy i just ask in my
questionnaire what is the
current monthly net income in euros
but how do i measure
people's extroversion now
through research did you
find out that you can measure the extra
version by following the straight out of
the big five personal trades
please indicate to what extent the
following characteristics apply to
you i am outgoing sociable
lively vivacious on a scale
of true not true
now we have a scale with four items
now of course the big question is how
well do these four items really
measure extraversion
so you create a poll on date
up de send it out and leave it to her
the answers in an excel tab  elle
output the excel table with the
example data can be found in the video
description
now you want to check whether the items have
a high internal consistency
and calculates the compass zeal the
compass alpha can be calculated with this formula
where the number of items
is dash the  average variance
and c dash the average intem
curve one between the items of course
you don't calculate the krombacher by
hand to others use a statistical
software how to do it and above all how to
interpret the results
i'll show you now for
this you just go to date up de
the link you will find a video
description copy your own data
into the table on data tab
and now are aprilia
we want to calculate the rehabilitation
sociable sociable lively and
spirited so
we will just calculate all four from
now and datatec automatically
have the compass zeal in this case
we enter the alpha  of
0.71 if we take a look at
this table, which gives us a
rule of thumb for the interpretation,
then it turns out that we have just
gotten an acceptable value.
the
items
are also interesting  has an influence
if you remove one of the four items
and what I then give for a compass
zeal we leave out the item sociable, for example
, then we get a
compass alpha of 0 66 it was
smaller that way we will
omit the variable sociable then
have  we even only get the
alpha of 0.48, but if we
omit the variable spirited
then we even have a higher compass
zeal then we get a compass
alpha of 0.79 so in this
case you could consider omitting the
item spirited  and thus
better results for the latent
variable extraversion gets
the data w  they were fictitious and of
course they don't really have any
meaning.
I would say just try it
yourself it's very easy and I
hope you liked the video
see you next time